- Dès les premières minutes de
l'événemen l le ton était donné.
DANIEL CÔTÉ, président de l'UMQ
- L'adaptation aux changements
climatiques,ioioioioioioioioioi.
- Aucun chef n'allait pouvoir
éviter le sujet chaud
sur ce parterre bondé
d'élus municipaux.
- C'est l'élection de
- Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois en a
ofofité pour éventer sa promesse
du jour : créer des sociétés
d'État pour le transportusususus
dans la province.
GABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, co-porte-
parole, Québec solidaire
le transport en commun, ça va
endetter nos enfants, mais pas
le 3e lien.
- Paul St-Pierre Plai i i i i i:
il promet 30 milliards
de dollars pour que les villes
développent leurs propres
systèmes deULULULULULULULULULUL,
chef, Parti québécois
- C'est vous, la solution.
Ce sera vos projets et nos
budgets
FRANCOIS LEGAULT, CHEF,
Coalition avenir Québec
- Ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait sacrifier
des constructions
- Les projets solidaires et
péquistes ne sont pas réalistes,
afaffirme François Legault,
car il manque de travailleurs
pour accélérer les projets
de construct M M M M M M M M M a
lui-même dû rétropédaler
sur un autre sujet.
- Je suis moins catégorique
que
par les journalistes.
Il faut qu'on respecte la
capacité de payer des Québécois.
- En début de semaine,
à l'idée de donner 2 milliards
de dollars aux municipalités
pour qu'elles s'adaptent
Devant les maires et mairess,,
il se dit maintent prêt
à discuter cocococococococococo,
y compris Éric Duhaime.ERIC DUHQ
- On propose, nous, de financer
notre transition énergétique
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe, PLQ
- Quand j'entends certaines
personnes nous dire que ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent que de faire
il y a aussi un énorme coû
à l'inertie.
- Des réponses qui sonnent
comme de la musique aux oreilles
des prin, , , , , , , , , , , ,l
- J'ai jamais autant entendu
collaboration, partenariat,
revoir la fiscalité, être
ouvert à discuter.
DANIEL CÔTÉ, président, UMQ
On a des engagements clair
de leur part.
- Hormis l'environnement,
d'autres sujets chers
mumumumumumumumumumumumumumumume
du logement, ont été abordés
aujourdhui. Mais chose certaine,
le prochain ou la prochaine
à devenir premier ministre aura
à toutes les attentes des maires
et mreresse du Québec.
Ici ALexandre Duval,